no to war they chant Russia without
Putin it isn't clear exactly who their
protest is aimed at they're Russians in
self-imposed Exile against the war in
Ukraine their presence tolerated by
staunch Kremlin allies Serbia one of
only a few countries to which Russians
can travel now visa-free
my voice might be a drop in the ocean
and maybe it won't be heard but I have
to speak out anyway Alexi novikov is
among an estimated 50 000 Russians
who've landed in Belgrade since war
broke out in February many on one-way
tickets
the pace of arrivals is thought to have
escalated in recent days with young men
in particular escaping President
Vladimir Putin's partial mobilization of
reservists
I don't want to take part in a war
against the Ukrainian people for some
unclear vague objectives and probably
very soon they will try to mobilize and
rush on mass and they will take anyone
they can catch and send them to the
front line to be used as Canon fodder
so-called brother Nations their fellow
Orthodox Slavs in Serbia offer the
Russians familiarity and a warm
reception but given the political ties
between Belgrade and the Kremlin it's an
unlikely Harbor for descent I feel that
people don't understand that Russians
are against the war they really feel
s they're not and that we are really
against the war no one is suggesting
that small expatriate populations like
this one however vocal are about to turn
public opinion in Russia against
President Putin or the war for one thing
it's highly unlikely they'll even be
seen or heard by most Russians on
state-run media but many people here do
feel that the recently announced
mobilization or call-up of reservists is
likely to bring a new awareness of the
war to Russian homes and Russian society
and that in turn is a step closer
towards a possible Tipping Point
it is one thing to sit on a couch and
contemplate how we are conquering
Ukraine and quite another to be in a
trench with a machine gun so I think
that the dissatisfaction of the people
is already quite strong because those
citizens who support Putin and the war
have started to express their
dissatisfaction with what is happening
in Ukraine and the mobilization now will
push people to protest against it from a
place of relative safety now having left
their old lives behind these Russian
dissenters are determined to play their
part Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Belgrade